thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air by clicking the
link in the description you'll also get
nebula for free streaming platform made
by and for creators like me you know how
normal people behave maybe you're one of
them you can hear a legal hypothetical
and then you can disregard it for save
the rest of your entire life I'm not one
of those people if I hear a legal
hypothetical I'm going to run down every
single permutation and every single
applicable law I can think of until I
have an answer it's sort of like how
Louis black when he overheard if I
weren't for my horse I never would have
gotten through college and and that's
all I could think of for the entire rest
of his day something like that happened
to me recently when I came upon a reddit
post that asked the question can I sue
my beekeeper neighbor apparently the
beekeepers bees were stealing the
neighbors pollen and turning it into
honey the question was also shared on
the popular social media hive known as
Twitter and if you don't think that this
video is going to be filled with all
kinds of bee puns you are sadly mistaken
my friend I've covered bee law before
and I'm not afraid to go back again
objection ah the non-low hair makes an
objection of course the beekeeper
neighbor sounds like the setup for a
horror movie about a man who roams the
neighborhood and a beekeeper outfit
terrorizing children on Halloween with
one of those little smoke canister
things not exactly sure how he would
kill people but you know that's for the
movie execs to figure out and I know
that this would be a straight to
streaming knockoff of Friday the 13th
but this redditors problem is more basic
than a serial killing beekeeper he
writes every day I see my neighbor's
bees flying around my garden stealing
the pollen or nectar from my flowers
then the bees go back to my neighbor and
creates honey my neighbor then harvest
the honey and sells it at the farmers
market for a profit I have never
received so much as a jar of honey as
compensation and every day my neighbor's
bees trespass and steal my flowers I was
stung once when I was a child so I know
how dangerous bees can be the way I see
it this is equivalent to a person's dog
coming into my yard to steal balls or
tools you know as dogs do then gives it
back to his owner who then sells it for
a profit
do I have legal grounds to sue what type
of things should I begin documenting in
order to prepare for a legal battle what
would be a fair settlement amount if my
neighbor doesn't want to take this to
court thanks for the help
this is so ridiculous so does this
redditor have the right to sue the
neighbor and his pesky bees for the
return of his extremely in quotes
valuable pollen let's find out now as
you may know there are 20,000 species of
bees in the world you may want to tell
bees to just buzz off but while bees
play a serious role in making sure
humans get to eat bees pollinate plants
that are not capable of reproducing
without the aid of bees the plants grow
up to produce fruit and vegetables that
we eat the Western honeybee is the
biggest pollinator in the world many
people domesticate and breed honeybees
for exactly this purpose it's a whole
cottage industry beekeepers are sort of
the hired guns of the agricultural world
they are hired and they bring a
truckload of bees to help pollinate
certain orchards in fact the demand for
almond milk has led to an increased
demand for bees now American beekeepers
have had great financial success renting
out their hive to commercial almond
producers however success comes at a
steep cost fifty billion bees were
annihilated in just a few months during
the winter of 2018 and 2019 the culprit
as you may know stems from the
herbicides and pesticides that are used
as well as the intense environment for
producing almonds the bees are forced to
work in a monoculture rather than a
biodiverse environment where bees
naturally thrive the worker bees are
stressed out used up and ultimately died
in what one scientist called warlike
circumstances he said it's like sending
the bees to war many don't come back
now I know I know you didn't come here
to listen to a monologue about the
plight of bees who work in sweatshops
you want to know about bee law now there
is such a thing as B law well not
exactly but there is a body of law that
deals with injury or damage caused by
wild and domesticated animals if you
were wondering when lawyers actually
deal with the law of wild animals you
might actually be surprised to know that
that's in the first year of law school
there are large sections of both
property and tort law that deals
specifically with wild animals
even though few lawyers if any actually
deal with wild animals on a regular
basis so let's break down this redditors
question first of all he's claiming to
be very angry that bees steal pollen
from his flowers which the bees then
used to create nectar in his view his
neighbor is therefore unreasonably
enriched by beekeeping he's saying all
this despite the real role that bees
play in keeping us fed and happy what a
buzzkill anyway under the law his
chances of successfully suing for
damages over the neighbors bees are slim
to none if there is a local law that
makes keeping bees on the property
illegal and the owner of the bees might
be liable for certain acts or omissions
or regular nuisance if bees attacked the
neighbor and the neighbor wasn't allowed
to have bees on the property to begin
with then that might be negligence per
se but obviously that isn't the
situation here realistically the man can
argue three legal theories for a lawsuit
conversion negligence and strict
liability so let's start with conversion
the person wants to sue for theft that
is known in civil courts as conversion
conversion is when someone does the
following without your consent they take
property and don't return it they sell
your property they make substantial
changes to the property such as cutting
down trees and I'm definitely gonna get
to the cutting down trees hypotheticals
on reddit in just a little while because
you guys are crazy for tree law or they
damage or misuse your property without
consent the elements of conversion the
things the plaintiff must prove to win
their case is that the person has a
legal right to the property that means
that they own it the defendant
intentionally interfered with possession
of the property and the defendants
actions caused the plaintiff to lose the
property to prove conversion
under these facts the guy who's so
buzzed off about the bees would have a
tough time first he'd need to show that
he had a legal right to the property
let's assume that he owns the flowers
but at Step two he may have a problem he
is to show that the neighbor
purposefully interfered with his
possession of the flowers
we can't know the intent of the bees
unless of course they are voiced by
Jerry Seinfeld like jazz and if we know
anything about bees we know that they
don't like to take direction you know I
don't think should we tell him I think
he knows I don't know what prompted them
to make this movie but it didn't exactly
have a lot of buzz for a secret sadly in
our conflict the intent that matters is
that of the neighbor did he own the bees
in question can the man prove it if so
can we infer that the beekeeper wanted
the bees to fly next door to pilfer the
pollen and but now you see the
difficulties with this argument and the
other element is proving damages to the
bees cause damage or injury or loss to
the plaintiff although the man does a
decent job of making the case he said
that the neighbor eventually makes money
by selling the honey that's also a
difficult argument no harm was done to
the flowers in fact you could argue that
the plants were enhanced by the bees
attention people pay good money for
having bees come to their property to
pollinate the different flowers there
and what about his hypothetical the way
I see it this is equivalent to a
person's dog coming to my yard to steal
balls or tools it gives it back to the
owner and who then sells it for profit
and he has a point
under the law if a person can prove that
the neighbors sent the dog into the yard
for the purpose of stealing the tools he
could have a claim for conversion in
fact in many states there are already
laws that prohibit a predator dog from
trespassing and hurting or killing
livestock on that yard and there's even
a common law rule that allows people to
kill dogs if necessary to protect
property you see an example of this and
the famous scene in To Kill a
Mockingbird but is this situation with
the bees directly analogous not really
the man has a lot to prove the ownership
of the bees the intent on the part of a
neighbor theft of something in a natural
world like pollen and actual damages
almost all of those are going to be a
huge problem in a claim for conversion
so let's talk about the second cause of
action negligence the legal definition
of
negligence is a failure to behave with
the level of care that someone of
ordinary prudence would have exercised
under the circumstances where someone
has a duty to act that way a person of
ordinary prudence is legalese for a
person who behaves appropriately this is
called the reasonable person standard
and as you can guess it's not always
easy to determine whether a person is
acting like a reasonable average human
being negligent conduct may consist of
an act or a failure to act when there is
a duty to do so if the person doesn't
have a legal duty to act then they can't
be negligent and in general people don't
have a duty to act for the benefit of
others unless the circumstances are such
that they give rise to a duty when might
you have a duty to act appropriately
well driving for example if you run a
red light and strike another car a court
could find you liable for negligence
this is because you had a responsibility
to act in a way that poses no danger to
other motorists when do you not have a
duty to act well a rescue for example
generally you don't have a legal duty to
rescue someone even if you're walking on
the beach and you see a stranger
drowning there's just no general duty to
risk your own life to save the life of
someone else's so let's talk about the
legal elements to a negligence claim
keep in mind that the law varies from
state to state but most jurisdictions
require a person to prove four things to
show negligence number one the existence
of a legal duty that the defendant owed
to the plaintiff to the defendants
breach of that Duty three plaintiffs
sufferance of an injury and four proof
that the defendants breach caused the
injury if an animal owner has acted
reasonably to prevent someone else from
being injured the plaintiff probably
won't be able to recover damages now is
there some negligence claim to be had
here
well maybe but probably not he would
have a much stronger case if the bee
stung him or caused some damage to his
property there aren't many published
negligence cases involving bees or even
bee stings since usually people aren't
stung unless the bees are provoked and
bees exist in the wild but one exception
was a Miami Beach apartment building
that had a massive beehive inside the
walls when the property manager went to
check out the apartments she got stung
and went to the ER when maintenance
workers found the hive honey had started
to drip down
walls and through the ceiling before the
building owners cleaned it up a tenon
slipped on the honey and fell down the
stairs this chain of events left the
apartment building owners with several
different lawsuits that cases eventually
settled for a combined 1.4 million
dollars but what's important here is
that the Miami Beach apartment building
knew they had a dangerous situation on
their hands the Beehive had been
discovered the building manager wound up
in the ER and honey was literally
dripping all over the floor here the
building owners had a duty to act a
billing owner must act as a reasonable
landlord towards the tenants but here
they didn't do anything about the
problem the tenant who slipped in the
honey has a typical slip and fall
negligence case but once again the
posters question doesn't quite measure
up nobody had a clear duty to stop the
bees from flying in the air to a
different property and the man can't
show that the neighbor breached a duty
unless there are other circumstances
like a law outlawing beekeepers in the
in the neighborhood and the man would
have trouble showing an injury his
plants weren't really harmed if anything
he got a benefit and since there's no
injury there's likely no monetary
damages either so let's talk about the
third and final cause of action there's
one more theory to pursue that's called
strict liability strict liability is
automatic liability that means that the
defendant is liable regardless of the
defendants intent or what they knew or
should have known at the time if
something happened and that gives rise
to strict liability you're strictly
liable if strict liability applies the
defendant must pay if his or her conduct
caused the plaintiffs injuries so for
example in a products liability case a
company who manages a defective product
that injures someone will be liable for
the plaintiffs injuries regardless of
whether the company knew there was some
serious or dangerous defect because
product liability is strict liability so
for example in 2016 Samsung's Galaxy
seven cell phone had a battery flaw that
caused them to spontaneously explode
class-action lawsuits have been filed on
the strict liability theory because the
cellphone is a product strict liability
also applies if someone creates an
abnormally dangerous condition or
ultra hazardous activities causing
injury to another person so if you are
driving a semi truck full of fireworks
maintaining a nuclear power plant or
storing dynamite these are the kind of
ultra hazardous activities that you'll
be strictly liable if someone is injured
regardless of whether you were negligent
and regardless of whether you knew that
there was a problem or not some
jurisdictions impose strict liability if
a pet attacks or bites someone so if you
have a pet circus tiger who malas your
neighbor you might get in trouble be
sure to check your local laws before
becoming the next Siegfried and Roy
states which impose strict liability for
injuries caused by animals often make a
distinction between domesticated animals
and wild animals remember I talked about
what you learn in law school well for
some reason we spend a huge amount of
time on the law of wild animals a wild
animal is normally considered to be one
that is quote not by custom devoted to
the services of mankind in the time and
place that it is kept people who own
wild animals are subject to strict
liability for injury caused to persons
or property by animals in their
possession
in contrast owners of domesticated
animals are generally only liable if
they are negligent whether an animal is
wild or domesticated varies from state
to state take the case of an aggressive
duck that's it no more mr. nice duck no
no not that one this one a woman sued a
neighbor in Oregon after she was
ambushed by an aggressive duck the
sketchy duck whose name is Lolita Rose
allegedly had attacked people before the
woman fell and broke her wrist and
injured her shoulder Oregon law applies
the strict liability rule for injuries
caused by domestic animals however under
Oregon law the owner has to be aware
that the animal has a propensity for
danger in practice this means that most
animals get one free nip or bite or
attack this is actually a common law and
you hear often about the one free bite
rule how else would a person know that
their pet duck or cat or bat has a
propensity for danger well legally the
plaintiff has to show that the animal
has injured someone in the past to prove
a theory of negligence the plaintiff
must show that the owner was negligent
or had knowledge that the duck was quite
dangerous and that the duck had caused
the woman's injuries now in the case of
the duck Lolita Rose the plaintiff said
that the duck's owner failed to properly
maintain control of her domesticated
animal failed to warn neighbors about
the dangerous duck in their myths and
failed to keep the duck contained on her
property she alleged both strict
liability and negligence as theories of
liability now returning to our B dilemma
the first question we have to answer is
whether the B's are wild or domesticated
the law may differ on us from state to
state but for the sake of argument let's
say that the B's are domesticated since
they are raised by the neighbor for
commercial purposes if this happened in
Oregon there could be liability on the
basis the neighbor knew the B's were
unbelievably mean and dangerous but this
theory of liability breaks down because
the B's didn't do anything dangerous or
hazardous or even mean for that matter
they didn't swarm the man or attack his
children or kill his dog they just
simply bugged him now all the B's did is
exactly what bees are meant to do
romance the flowers and we talked about
this briefly but maybe it's actually a
boon to the neighbor to have his flowers
pollinated if that's the case it might
actually be that the neighbor who claims
that the pollen was stolen actually owes
money to the neighbor under a theory of
quantum erowid or promissory estoppel if
this gave rise to a contract if he knew
he was getting a benefit and knew that
the neighbor would have charged him for
that service maybe he's the one that
owes money to his neighbor so my advice
to the original redditor is pretty
simple just ask your neighbor for a jar
of honey and let it be now if you're the
type of person that loves getting
dubious legal advice from reddit
you'll love the nebula and curiosity
stream bundle because nebula is where I
put my extended in unrated videos as
well as my bloopers for example you
might have noticed a new series on this
channel called the case of it's an
animated recreation of real true crime
cases in some of the most famous legal
trials in history like the case of the
shotgun booby trap and the case of the
genius murderers
Leopold and Loeb you can see some of
those on YouTube but nebula lets me put
up my uncut versions that I actually
can't show on YouTube it's still illegal
eagle but now with 10% more murder and
in fact I'm putting up a version of this
episode up on nebula that doesn't have
ads and it has all of the bloopers from
this video because it can be hard on
YouTube when you're dealing with
sensitive subjects because the only
thing scarier than murder is getting
demonetized which is why my Creator
friends and I teamed up to build our own
platform where creators don't need to
worry about D monetization and the
dreaded algorithm it's called nebula and
we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiosity stream nebula is a place where
creators can do what we do best create
it's a place where we can both house our
content ad free and also experiment with
new original series that probably
wouldn't work on YouTube and when I say
that nebula is built by creators for
creators I really mean it nebula
features lots of YouTube's top
educational ish creators like Thomas
Frank knowing better H bomber guy and
tier zu as well as tons of others we get
to collaborate in ways that wouldn't
work on YouTube and we get to work
together on nebula exclusive videos that
will never be on YouTube the project is
self-funded not backed by investors and
we've managed to make this and free with
no dreaded algorithm so what does this
have to do with curiosity stream well as
the Internet's go-to place for
documentaries and long-form educational
content they love educational creators
so they were the perfect partner for
nebula and in fact we just worked out a
deal where if you sign up for curiosity
stream with a link in the description
not only will you get one free month of
curiosity stream but you'll also get a
nebula subscription for free and to be
clear that nebula subscription is not a
trial it's free for as long as your
curiosity stream member which means that
if you sign up for curiosity stream
which is less than $20 a year not only
do you get unlimited access to curiosity
streams massive library of gorgeous high
budget documentaries but you'll also get
to enjoy the private playground of
YouTube's best educational creators for
no additional charge in fact one of my
favorite curiosity stream documentaries
is Peter sagal 'he's history which
explains how some of the pivotal events
in US history are tied to money
including Watergate and the Civil War
they even have documentaries about the
secret lives of bees so just click on
the link in the description to get the
curiosity stream nebula
bundle you get both curiosity stream and
nebula and you'll be supporting creators
like me directly or you can go to
curiosity stream comm slash legal eagle
but seriously just click on the link in
the description you won't be
disappointed
so do you agree with my legal analysis
about bee paralysis leave your
objections in the comments and check out
this playlist over here with all of my
other reactions to Reddit and your
favorite movies and me explaining how
everything is just illegal so click on
this playlist and I'll see you in court